I think where I get the most sad
sometimes is like man this this could be
forever for the rest of my life that I
have to live with this that's what
that's where I can get a little sad like
it's going to it's going to be a little
hard forever probably I think so you
have to always have hope and it's not
false hope because it's it's not like
we're in the 1700s and you don't
know what the hell is going on I have a
lot of Hope but I think that I have
learned that it's better to not think
about that too much because it can take
me so far away from what it is now it it
the the more accepting I am getting in
the now the less pressure I feel about
it yeah you don't want it to consume you